[Captions by Y Translator]
In today's video,
we're going to try freezing Lego
to cryogenic temperatures,
and throwing it
in a blender to see
if we can turn it into a powder.
[Music]
Hey guys, I'm Nate.
I'm Calli, and today we
have a pile of Lego bricks,
some liquid nitrogen,
and a Blendtec
and a Lego Bugatti,
because it's beautiful,
and we're going to see what we
can do with all these things.
The goal here is to try
and make powderized Lego.
We want to see
if we can take these bricks,
and turn them into dust.
We thought a good powerful
blender might do that,
but it would
probably work better
if we can drop them down to
cryogenically cold temperatures
before we throw them in.
Lego bricks are made from
what's called ABS plastic,
and it starts to melt at around
200 degrees Fahrenheit,
but gets to a really
runnier thinner consistency used
for injection molding at around
400 degrees Fahrenheit.
All right.
So here's the basic idea.
We are going to be taking
some Lego pieces, dipping them
into liquid nitrogen,
and pulverizing them
in a Blendtec to see
if we can powderize them.
If we can, we may try
melting them down.
Guys, I just really
like destroying things.
One Lego brick.
Ready?
Sure.
[Music]
Yes, this is very effective.
I'm gonna try--
It has a higher speed setting it gets to.
[Music]
I'm going to go ahead and say
if you stepped on that,
it would be a lot
less painful than normal.
Yeah, we've just made
like Lego sand here, I think.
No, this is Lego gravel.
We're not to the sand point yet.
Wait, is it?
It's kind of a slight
burning plastic smell.
Yeah.
It's like...
Have you ever left
like a cutting board
on your stove accidentally?
Kind of smells like that.
All right.
So here's what we've got left.
Let's just pour this out.
So this was a Lego brick,
and now, it's Lego gravel,
as Calli has called it.
Looks like Fruity Pebbles.
Look at this.
We can try the
Fruity Pebbles colors.
Yes. No. Yes.
[Music]
It's really hot.
I think the process of blending
it has actually heated it up.
So the friction and
the kinetic energy is really,
it's really playing
a lot into that.
So we have tried pulverizing
just regular Lego in the blendtec,
and as you saw,
it didn't really work.
We kind of got a Fruity Pebbles.
It's blended, but I
wouldn't call it powderized.
So to try and get
this a little bit more powdery,
we're going to see
what happens if we freeze
the Lego bricks first,
and for that,
we've got some liquid nitrogen.
We're just going to take
these down to several
hundred degrees below zero,
and see what happens when we
throw them in the blender.
Calli is freezing a brick.
I will take a different brick.
This is normal
unfrozen brick, pliers.
It's ruined, but that like...
It just got kind of crushed,
little bit of smooshing.
Let's see what happens
if we do it with a frozen brick.
>> All gone.
>> Yup.
Let's try freezing a few bricks,
and throwing them
in the blender.
Pour in our liquid nitrogen
into this pot,
because we've got
this cool little frying thing.
We're going to use that to dip
the Lego pieces down in.
That looks like a good mix.
Yeah.
Go go go.
[Music]
I suspected this point,
it is now warmed up.
So let's take a look at this.
That went much faster,
and we have
no large pieces left.
I'm not sure if I
would call this a powder,
but I think we are
definitely to a sand state.
Did you inhale it?
I think some got
in my mouth something.
As you can see,
the frozen Lego
definitely breaks up
into much smaller bits.
We've got our little Lego figure
of Grant here and...
He's not going to make it.
We want to see what happens
if we blend up Lego Grant,
so we're going to
blend up Lego Grant.
Sorry Grant.
No!
Ow.
I'm melting--
Nope.
Freezing.
I'm freezing.
Sorry Grant.
[Music]
Goodbye, Grant.
And he's gone.
Oh, he dead.
Well, we've got black element.
We've got blue element.
We have yellow element,
and some orange element.
Also, the little hose
to his blowtorch,
just like completely survived.
Wait, is that
different material?
I don't know.
I think it was just so thin
that it warmed
up really quickly.
But it does make
me wonder though,
different types of materials.
Legos have cars.
Cars have tires.
Tires are rubber.
What does that do?
Let's find out.
Goodbye, Grant.
Lego tire, squishy rubber.
Fun fact: Lego is the biggest
tire manufacturer in the world.
As long as you count
that as a full size tire.
[Music]
Good and frozen, lets blend it.
Mmm, yum.
Oh no, tire.
[Music]
I think we should try
blending up a whole car.
Not that car.
That won't fit in our blender.
Pulverize Bugatti?
I don't want to do that.
How about this one?
Perfect.
[Music]
People like putting
Lego pieces together.
So we just need to put
this back together.
This would be a beginner
level Lego assembly.
One to six months.
[Music]
That's a car.
There is a cup full of car.
I think that the larger pieces
do a better job of blending up,
because there's more like weight
holding it down near the blades.
So I do want to try
like a larger batch of Lego.
[Music]
Wow!
>> That looks really fine.
>> It looks like sand.
Yeah, all the
colors mixed together.
And as fine as it got
with the larger volume.
Oh, looks less like sand.
It looks like sand mixed with--
Oh, but that.
That dust.
Nice.
Now, we still have some pretty
darn large chunks in there,
but this is the finest
we've gotten so far.
[Music]
Now, we're going to grab several
different individual colors,
and blend those separately, so we
get different colors of powder.
[Music]
We've got a couple
of these glass trays,
and we're going to take
our Lego powder, sand, dust
whatever you want to call it,
and we're going to pour it in.
In one tray,
we're going to take
our just mixed up
assorted rainbow colors.
We're just going to kind of put
that in along with the other
cups we've blended,
except the car because
that has rubber tires,
and we wouldn't want to do that.
The other one,
I've cut out this Lego
man shaped stencil,
and we're going to try and pour
in the different colors,
and get kind of
a Lego man shape out of it.
Will it actually work?
We'll see, but it's...
Might be abstract art.
[Music]
Yeah, let's throw these
in an oven at 400 degrees,
and see how they handle it.
[Music]
This has been in
here for a while.
I really thought
that things were going
to start puddling down,
but it looks like we're getting
some burning and some smoke.
Clearly, that has burned.
That looks kind of like...
Well, now we've got
dark Fruity Pebbles.
Okay, weird.
Do you see this?
It's really not
conductive, is it?
No, the surface, I can touch.
Like it's very warm.
Yeah.
But if I'm only
touching it lightly,
it doesn't [inaudible].
If I start to squish it,
then it burns.
Don't do this at home kids.
But look at this.
This is like, you see how gooey.
[Music]
So it's...
It's definitely all congealed.
Oh, wait!
As soon as I took it out though,
now it's--
Now, it's gone brittle.
Oh, not even brittle.
That's strong.
[Music]
Not conductive.
Super hot.
But as soon as
that comes off the pan,
I'm touching that.
[Music]
Well, okay.
So here's...
Here's the real question.
We want this to come
out in one piece.
But all it takes is me
just sort of scraping this,
and you can see it's leaving
this horrid residue.
So I don't know if that's going to
come out once we cool it down.
Just curious how this is a...
That's cool.
What?
That's like the
colors we wanted.
Although you can see there's
like little bits of the burned
color coming through.
That side's hot.
Don't touch that side.
And then like, it's spilled.
These are now cool down
and it's stuck.
It's very stuck to the bottom.
So that's in there forever.
If it was an abstract,
and you sort of cross
your eyes a little bit...
Modern Art.
You could probably find
that in a museum
in New York somewhere.
This is for sale
for 1.9 million dollars.
Contact me.
[Music]
Guys, that's it for today,
but the fun doesn't end here.
We've got more for you see.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video.
You should check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe to the channel.
That way, you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you on the next one.
Talk to you then.